if you're looking for a thin lightweight
in premium Windows laptop both the
surface laptop 3 and XPS 13 2 and 1 are
great choices we have full detailed
reviews of both of these laptops which
you can check out on a channel but in
this video we're gonna compare both of
these to see which one is the better buy
at multiple price points they both start
at $9.99 packing Intel's latest and
greatest 10 animator ice Lake processors
the surface definitely has a more
simplistic and clean design if you get
the $1,300 model which is full aluminum
whereas the XPS uses a carbon fiber
material which isn't as premium but it
is more comfy to type on just like the
ala contra on some of the surface
configurations the XPS comes with a
fingerprint scanner that doubles as a
power button but the surface laptop 3
actually comes with an infrared facial
scanning that actually scans your face
and automatically logs you in as soon as
you open up your laptop I would honestly
have this over any kind of fingerprint
sensor because it's so much more
convenient the surface laptop 3 display
comes with a 3 by 2 aspect ratio which
has a lot of extra vertical space for
browsing the web compared to the XPS 16
by 10 ratio which is a bit wider but
that's actually a great middle ground
between 3 by 2 and 16 by 9 because it
also allows a laptop itself to be
smaller probably the best thing about
the XPS is display is the super thin
bezels being so much slimmer than the
ones on the surface laptop 3 another
issue with the surface is that the
display is really reflective and even
though the display gets pretty bright it
doesn't get bright enough to counteract
the reflectivity while the XPS of
display is less reflective and it gets
even brighter this speck of the XPS
actually comes with a 4k display but the
regular 1200 P display gets just as
bright with the same low reflectivity
both of these packed touch screen
displays but the XPS S hinge can bend
all the way back and go into tablet mode
which gives you a much more convenient
touchscreen experience if that's what
you're into my biggest gripe about the
XPS S hinge is that it gets really stiff
before the display reaches a viewable
angle which is really annoying
appear to a very well-made hinge on the
surface in terms of keyboards the
surface has more key travel but it lacks
feedback whereas the keys on XPS have a
really good balance between key travel
and the nice springy feel that kind of
pushes back at you which makes it more
satisfying to type on I also love how
the XPS s keyboard goes edge to edge
while the surface has quite a bit of
waste of space on the sides now for the
track pads both are quite good but the
surface actually has a little bit more
of a satisfying feel getting into
speaker quality the surface laptop three
blows the XPS speakers out of the water
[Music]
now for the ports the surface keeps the
old school with a USB type a port a USB
sea ports in a MagSafe style charging
connector that quickly disconnects if
anybody trips over the cable the XPS on
the other hand comes with a Thunderbolt
3 port on each side and a mini SD card
slot the beauty of Thunderbolt 3 is that
you have a lot of extra bandwidth for
connecting things like high-speed SSDs
top-of-the-line accessories multiple 4k
displays and even external graphics
cards now let's compare performance
specs and value at three different price
points for $9.99 the surface laptop 3 is
a surprisingly good value getting 8 gigs
of ram and i5 processor with g7 graphics
and just 128 gigs of ram but more on
that in just a bit the XPS only gets 4
gigs of ram and i3 processor with g1
graphics but it does get 256 gigabytes
of storage
comparing processor performance the
surface definitely wins here especially
getting a huge boost and multi-core
score and the difference in graphics
performance is massive as well not only
is the surface a much better performer
at this price point it also comes with
the same good quality display as the
top-end spec whereas the lower price
Dells come with a 1200 P display which
kind of seals the deal for the surface
now at the $1,300 price point the
surface gets full aluminum and 256
gigabytes of storage whereas the XPS
gets a gigs of ram and an i5 processor
but the same slow graphics so the
surface pro is still a better Buy if you
don't need Thunder both three now every
other option above $1,300 comes with the
same i7 processor and graphics so the
surface loses its performance advantage
and the lack of Thunderbolt 3 and the
more reflective display really starts to
stand out the higher-end dulles can come
with 4k displays which are sharper more
color accurate and less reflective at a
trade-off in battery life which the
surface laptop 3 comes in right in
between around 8 hours of real world use
you can even get 32 gigabytes of RAM on
the XPS which most people don't need but
if you plan to connect and
GPU for video editing or run other
programs that can utilize this Ram such
as Lightroom classic this extra Ram can
really help quite a bit
the surface does have a trick up its
sleeve which is the SSD that isn't a
standard design and although it's not
easy to access it can actually be
swapped out in the future
which is really nice especially if you
buy the base model at the lower price
points if you don't need Thunderbolt 3 I
would definitely buy the surface because
of its minimalistic but premium design
great performance instant Windows hello
facial recognition and the excellent
hinge and also the much louder speakers
but if you're looking at the high-end
configs we would suggest XPS because it
does offer a better display potentially
more RAM and Thunderbolt 3 no matter
which laptop you prefer we will have
links the best deals on both of them
down in the description below if you
enjoyed this comparison tap like and
click that circle above to subscribe for
more videos and you guys can see the
full reviews of both of these laptops
right over there there's been max max
tech and I will see you in the next
video
[Music]